and uh and you said that that back in
the day that they're you know with with
the partying i i'm pretty amazed
that
that you seem to have just put it down
you know like all of the the you know
the crazy pills and the whiskey and
yeah no i i still have drinks now and
now and again uh but
the pills i put down um
and
did you have to do anything to put put
them down
was it just like probably when you have
kids you probably want to tone it down a
bit right yeah sure yeah well i mean
with madison like it kind of was the
opposite
you know i i wouldn't he wasn't ready
yet i wasn't ready yet and like i
wouldn't because i would see my father
drunk and i didn't want
her to see me drunk so i try not to
do that at home yeah right but i go out
and just get smashed
so i was yeah there were points in my
life where i was
partying way too much
yeah
um did it just kind of phase out or was
there a moment where like i gotta make a
change
um
it i think after number two
you know and i yeah i got together with
naomi and
started
uh calming down then
yeah i would notice that because
on number two and you've said this
plenty that we were all on our absolute
worst oh my god
and everything that we did just worked
so like everything we did on camera like
just worked so well in that movie it was
like
god
and uh and
yeah your uh free time was all just
about behaving badly partying and then
four years later jackass 3d
like it just seemed like you
you had done an about phase you were a
totally different guy there was no bad
behavior there was no partying you were
just singularly focused on pouring all
of your time and energy into trick nut
shots
okay like you really you traded when you
traded like one of the ones
totally yeah
i i think that's fair i was uh
i would get obsessed with shooting
and also i think
maybe it's a fair
thing to
put out there that i may have been
addicted to doing the larger stunts the
stunts that
really could take me out i think i got
really
obsessed in that too which i'm still
coming out of right right
because i know i can never get in with
another bull again
but
i physically miss it